hello and welcome to this video playing
Kira malu or not yeah I'm also blocked
out after the last game that was a
frustrating game I defend the whole time
and then you blunder look in one move
him great okay so let's just beat cure
model now and get some points back
that's the plan any time on below 2500 I
feel like something is wrong there yeah
the black set up this is pretty awful
here I've got a fantastic type of /
sneak off him so let's see I have to
think about this for a moment if 95 is
already good or just move it I can't
even I mean Bishop takes a three it's
not really all that terrible the thread
95 is extremely strong it's not even
doing anything here against it
what are we a position came on da de can
also take or take this ya wanna take
them how to do this looks right here to
attack this immediately maybe 94
[Music]
and set way to use black king on the
eight this is our d 8 this is the thing
I don't know
but unsure this is good it's the only
really forceful way of doing things
really I wanted to take one in seven and
then clay be five and said I'd take
behind immediately yeah losing against
this opening is not really a good thing
to do but ok maybe you can still maybe I
can still find a bit data to pawn some
still on some more dangerous
yeah how do I get them get the book into
the game not so easy
a king on c5 actually looks quite good
I never puts licking them somehow
threatening g5
okay so I am so he wants to return the
material there and then ok some idea no
it doesn't want to return material ok so
can check only three hmm yeah but maybe
this one actually ok lets him take this
and take a form the a point is actually
quite strong
time learning
check what check and this is that he
calculated amazing
is winning for black unfortunately
if you lose start to lose against
openings like that things are not going
well check
yeah still losing unfortunately like
resinize have to because double double
loss you have those quite often ur
simply so upset about some game and that
that opening is completely unplayable
for like this stuff it just completely
rotten let's put down engine on and see
how I could have killed him so plus 1
year so I should take twice look age six
and this thing is already over so it's
easy yeah I mean what kind of position
is that you just go here and and it's
it's Bates really over yeah and this
isn't isn't clear having this I if I at
least take on his hammer my this is just
like I'm just blundering this in one
move and then basically anybody can win
okay yeah that was pretty an easy to
convert I just take on f6 and again this
place to play over yeah I don't know I
do I wasn't thinking thinking clearly
damn probably I should just make take a
small break after such a game like the
one before that's probably the right way
to do it because simply cannot play
decently after losing the ina in a bad
way and this is not exactly rocket
science here to take on it typically and
play here I mean this is really easy
okay thanks for watching